I love that nobody's ever called me that
but I think you're right the one thing
I'll say is if you believe in what
you're doing don't sell it to somebody
self publish it when you start to find
the courage to show up to speak up to
own the parts of your story that
completely blow and that are
embarrassing and full of shame you will
find the freedom that you don't feel
right now either because nobody's ever
asked me that question hey guys it's the
bow show and today's guest is one of my
favorite people in the world if she was
here I'd give her a big hug is this
sensational Mel Robbins Mel how are you
I'm fantastic and I'd give you a hug
right back though what a week it's been
four you've just released your audible
talk show kick ass with Mel Robbins
which I went through twice because I
just had to listen to it and it's funny
to get out of it what did you get out of
it oh the story about Marcus as someone
as someone who is a speaker and a coach
trying to help the world embracing my
own vulnerability really helped and my
own story and this is what this whole
thing is about it's inspiring people and
having people like yourself come on here
and just if you guys don't know Mel
Robbins Mel gave me the one of the my
first ever interviews on my own channel
four-minute masters and it was from that
this collaboration with Evans come on
and now we're we're just going to take
over the world
why not life yes it's just over a year
since the five-second rule
was released and you've just exploded
and I think what we'd like to just know
is how's your life changed because
you're no longer the five-second rule
lady you are you're a transformational
machine that nobody's ever called me
that but I think you're right
maybe I'm just addicted to reinvention
because I get tired of myself is that
what happens when you have a Dede it's
been a insane year on so many levels and
so just to bring everybody up to speed a
year ago February 28th I believe it was
we launched the five-second rule book
and there are so many lessons
not only the launch of that book and how
I did it as a businesswoman but also the
trajectory that has happened since then
number one it's important for you to
know that it was one of the top five
most read books on Amazon last year it
was the number one audio book in the
world it is the number one selling title
on Amazon and audible self-publishing
audible platform that's really cool
because as an entrepreneur for me
personally it's so important for me to
kind to have control of the work that
I'm doing that decision to self publish
has paid off more than it's paid off
financially and it certainly will pay
you more in the long tail financially
when you own your work and when you self
publish and if you have an idea that you
have been thinking about and you're
watching both show and you're watching
Evans channel to get the motivation to
continue to tell your story to do the
work to get your stuff out there the one
thing I'll say is if you believe in what
you're doing don't sell it to somebody
self publish it because you will
eventually it might not happen in the
first year but eventually your work will
bump into the right audience and it will
grow and it will grow and you will
really regret having sold for pennies on
the dollar the thing that was really
your life's work and so please please
please if you are content generator if
you're an entrepreneur if you're a
writer if you're a song producer on what
you're doing at least in the beginning
until you start to understand the
industry and the economics of things so
it was a huge queue to be a
self-published author and to have that
kind of phenomenon happened we are
approaching a million copies sold the
book has been translated into 31
languages and what's changed about my
life is a number of things so the most
important thing that has changed is that
the five-second rule because it's such a
simple idea and it's so easy to share
and it has so much science behind it it
has spread around the world and the
thing that's changed the most about my
life though
is that you know we've been hearing from
people every day for five years right
that have been using the five four three
two one count backwards method in order
to change habits and and develop the
skill of self-control but the profound
thing that has happened for me is that
we have heard from more than forty four
people who have not committed suicide
because they have used the rule to stop
themselves in fact three days ago three
days ago we received an email from a
woman who's nineteen year old son died
and she was overcome with grief as any
parent or human being would be and that
grief has taken her down the rabbit hole
of self-harm and major depression and
she was literally standing at the edge
of the river and standing there
deliberating about whether or not she
was going to wade in because she
couldn't bear the grief anymore she used
the five-second rule to turn herself
around interrupt those thoughts and go
back to her truck then she used the
five-second rule five four three two one
to pick up the phone and call her
husband and tell him what was going on
then she used the five-second rule -
five four three two one find the courage
to call an emergency room and get the
help that she needed the other thing
that I am really proud of is that it's
now being used with veterans
organizations around the world to help
our veterans live with PTSD and they use
the count backwards method five four
three two one
to interrupt the connection between the
trigger and the destructive thing that
they feel or do and - five four three
two one interrupt that association and
develop new habits for the things that
we're triggering their PTSD of course
you know in combination with therapy and
professional support but the fact that
such a simple idea is changing people
around the world it has it has fueled me
in a way with a level of conviction and
a amount of responsibility that has
changed the kind of leader that I am
that
changed the impact and the confidence
that I have about the number of people
that we can help and reach and inspire
and ignite a breakthrough in and it has
also given me a very clear direction
about the kind of platform that I want
to build as we provide inspiration and
tactical practical ways that people can
fight the things that stop them so I've
been utterly transformed by the people
that have been writing to us from around
the world about how the five-second rule
is changing their lives like you're an
innovator as well and your new audible
is it's a first there's yeah there
hasn't been a talk-show like that no
listening to your audible your your
five-second rule and then hearing you
you can actually hear how different you
are you're a lot more comfortable and
it's brilliant because again that goes
into my next thing I want to talk about
your embracing your own authenticity yes
and you're becoming the best version of
yourself and one of the things I said
earlier I took away from the book was I
had a horrific few years but as soon as
I embraced who I truly was and stopped
hiding in shadows and started casting
lights on it
man I'm where I am today it's free isn't
it when you stop using pretending and
hiding and doing all the things that
shrink you and deplete you like lying
and procrastinating and silencing
yourself or sticking around people that
are toxic when you start to find the
courage to show up to speak up to own
the parts of your story that completely
blow and that are embarrassing and full
of shame you will find the freedom that
you don't feel right now I just I I'm
not a crier but there were moments when
listening to your thing I felt a tear
coming up in goosebumps I don't to give
too much away but it's you're really
embracing I think the overall thing is
you said in your TED talk we're four
hundred trillion to one yeah and I don't
think enough of us realize what an
incredible miracle we actually are like
we've won the lotto already let's act
like winners well you know the thing is
is that there's a cut there's a couple
things I want to say so in the TED talk
I say
this this statistic that I had read
years ago and that is that a scientist
have calculated the odds of you and me
being born and when you think about just
even the sexual act of your parents in a
lifetime relationship the number of
times they would actually be intimate
the amount of sperm that go the odds of
one egg and one sperm and then you throw
in then you throw in the DNA and the
uniqueness of your DNA structure some
scientists calculated all of those odds
and figured out that the odds of you
being you who you are born the day that
you were born to the parents that you
have with the DNA structure that you
have given all the other variables that
could have changed something the odds
are one in four hundred trillion that
you are you and so what that means to me
is that you're meant to be here that
there is a reason why you were born and
the journey of your life is to figure it
out and I think it's actually simple I
think that life is very simple and we
complicate it because we have brains
that can tell stories and we have bodies
that can sense danger and so we over
complicate things and that the purpose
of your life is to listen to your heart
and soul and to follow it and to express
the highest version of you not the self
doubt not the anxiety not the fear is
not the pettiness not the frustrations
but to actually have the courage to be
fully expressed as as like it sounds
stupid but you know as as a great human
being
to have the courage to be kind to have
the courage to be patient to have the
courage to cheer for other people and
have the courage to tune into that
wisdom that's inside of you and lean
into it follow the things that pique
your curiosity do more of the [ __ ] that
actually expands your heart and expands
the amount of energy in your body and
slowly but surely if you align all your
decisions and the things that you spend
time on and the people that you spend
time on with the things that natch
energize you your whole life will
experience a shift and so back to the
the talk show something that happened
for me after the five-second rule book
became so successful is we obviously got
a lot of inbound requests right because
when you prove to the world that you
have something that the world wants and
that you can make a lot of money doing
it too and you're a successful
businesswoman now everybody wants to
play so every single television
production company and radio and
podcasts and even corporations reaching
out to us saying hey would you consider
doing something if we were the
advertiser and not it was interesting
because I've learned about myself that
and somebody else controls me and I am
talent in someone else's game everything
that I produce sucks I resent the people
that I'm working with and I hate the
process and it's taken me ten years in
the media business to figure this out
what I'm talented and when somebody else
tells me what to do and controls the
final product
I'm depleted when I'm a businesswoman
and I'm creating content I'm energized
so audible came to us because we were
number one and obviously and this is the
other cool thing is there's no
production cost ongoing when you record
a book when you print a book you have to
print it you have to store it you have
to ship it there could be a return which
is more printing and storing and
shipping and so there's so many costs
associated with it which is why that
industry is so constrained and very it's
very hard for it to innovate because of
the cost structure of it but audible and
audio once you record the file you're
done so they came to us and said would
you do an exclusive with us on your next
book and I said no definitely not going
to do that on the next book but I would
definitely consider doing an advise talk
show but here's the here's the catch my
team has to produce it we have to you
know do a partnership deal where we have
full creative control and we will hand
you what we've finished
and you can do all the post will pick
the music
will dictate what's in what's out but
we'll partner that way and they said yes
and so we did a global casting called as
you know bow we got 500 submissions I
bet if we do season 2 we'll get five
thousand submissions and we narrowed it
down to eight people eight people that
represent a wide range of problems that
people could relate to that are good
talkers that come from diverse
backgrounds and diverse set of issues
and we flew them all to Boston and we
put them in a tiny little studio and
they got a coaching session for me and
then we produced it in two must like if
you if you think about television that's
like much must watch television oh my
god and the theme is coming and now I
got a watch house of cards or The
Bachelor or whatever it is we produce
television in your ear we produce a talk
show that's gonna take you on a
rollercoaster of a ride as you listen to
other people's problems you're gonna
realize you're not alone you're gonna
see yourself in other people's stories
and you're going to have breakthroughs
as they're having breakthroughs because
you're gonna be listening literally
right in the session as we're talking
it's that power of the asking yourself
the question and although you have all
those as you said you got a spectrum of
people on that talk show I could relate
and I know everyone else listening to it
can you got there's a bit of me in that
and then you go am i doing that right
and it's forgiveness it's acceptance and
but I just I will be listening to again
and of people think I like I'm sponsored
by you cuz I'm forcing it I love it I
think it's the change we immediately you
know bow I rarely say this but I am
extraordinarily proud of what we created
because our team we have a very lean
team and most of the people I've been in
the the media business for 10 years but
I've never created a show my business
partner and I she was my radio producer
on an award-winning radio talk show but
it wasn't an advice talk show it was a
kind of discussed current events
interview kind of show we'd never
produced anything like that and we
literally created it from now
and so I'm extraordinarily proud of what
we actually got done and the impact that
it's making and you know that's another
thing for everybody for you to
understand as you're watching Bo and I
talk and that is this that very rarely
very rarely does somebody who throws
their hat over the rig and then decides
that they're gonna just figure out how
to pursue something very rarely is it a
wholesale failure you always discover
what you're looking for when you're
willing to hear what's in your heart
when you have the clarity to do that and
when you have the courage to pursue it
and it may not turn out how you like it
may not be the blockbuster that you
thought it would you know I kind of feel
Bo like I've been training in the dark
for ten years I mean I've hosted a
reality show for Annie I hosted a
reality show for Fox that never aired I
was a commentator for CNN
I had a syndicated radio show none of
which ever felt right and none of those
things were actually very successful you
know I mean ultimately monster-in-law
was canceled the show I shot with Fox
never aired that's not successful but
what I learned in those projects led me
to being able when the moment came to
meet the moment and to have the
confidence to say no I'm not going down
the road of being talent again I'm gonna
produce this thing myself with my team
and we're gonna follow our instincts and
it also gave me the skill set you see I
didn't just show up to a mic I had been
preparing to launch that talk show for
ten years and here's actually a story
that I haven't told a lot of people so
when I first got into the media business
10 years ago there was an article
written about my life and business
coaching practice and and somebody from
ink magazine wrote an article about it
and an executive from CNBC called and so
I went down for
meetings and after meeting a bunch
networks ended up signing with ABC to be
developed into a talk-show host that was
10 years ago I spent a year with ABC
getting coached by them to host a talk
show at the end of the year they didn't
resign me though so he was a failure
okay
they never launched a show it was a
failure and I remember the executive
who's a very dear friend of mine now a
gentleman by the name of Hank Norman who
would be amazing for you to also
interview one of the original creators
of the view by the way uh he knows what
he's talking about he looked at me and
he said I want to tell you something
they'll you're never gonna be successful
you need to move to New York you cannot
do what you want to do living in Boston
you have to be in New York and that's
part of the reason why we're not gonna
resign you because you're just not
committed and I looked at him and I said
you know what someday I'm gonna host a
talk show in Boston
and I'm gonna produce the whole thing
myself and I'm gonna own it
just like Oprah Winfrey did when she
moved her show to Chicago you watch me
and I'll be damned if this thing didn't
launch next week and the first text
message I got was from Hank Norman and
he said I'll be damned you were right
and I am so proud of you you gotta stick
to your guns and you never know how it's
gonna turn out you guys but when you
listen to your heart and you keep moving
forward you get rewarded and you also
get the lessons that you need it's how I
got this I said not on the scale what
you're doing but I I did an interview
with Gary Vaynerchuk and I was like this
is it I'm gonna explode I still and I'm
very proud of this have the lowest
viewed Gary Vaynerchuk
interview of all time I'm so proud but
it led me to other things and now we're
doing this and this channel we got
millions of people on here and it's an
honor and it's just again I followed my
heart I could have given up but I kept
going and one of the things I was going
to talk about with you is if we could
because most of people on here are
entrepreneurs but you're this whole
discussion has just been gold nugget
after gold nugget and
gonna I want the viewer to find the gold
that you've been talking in this because
there's so much in there about
self-publishing following your heart
literally retaining your own rights and
doing it your way and here's here's
another massive insight so I always
think about businesses levels right and
I also realize that is the median
landscape or the particular vertical or
industry that you're building a business
and is changing that is a constant and
it's something that you can't control
right you just cannot control the things
that are happening in the world around
us but you can always control what
you're thinking and what you're doing in
response to it so all of my work centers
inside this gap between what's happening
in your life and in your work and what
your reaction is to it and how you can't
control the things that are going on
around you but you can always control
what your reaction is and that gap there
that's about five seconds long and you
start to understand that you can change
how you think you can change your habits
you can change how you lead you can
pivot and change even the philosophy of
your company and you can do it through
the decisions that you're making and
managing your reactions
you will become unstoppable so three
years three and a half years ago I got
into the speaking business because of
the popularity of that TEDx talk that I
gave and that first year I did I don't
know I think was like 27 speeches the
next year I did 87 last year I did 121 I
was the most booked female speaker in
the world this year I've capped it at 80
and here's why I realized just like you
may be realizing in your business
whatever your business is that there are
aspects of your business that you love
and that energize you and there are
aspects of your business that are
depleting as hell and that are old and
that are tired and that if you continue
in that lane you're gonna end up ten
years from now in a place that you don't
want to be it's so important for you to
pay attention to what's energizing you
about the landscape around you and about
your own business because that's the
secret to seeing around corners and so
the corner that I was seeing around is
that as an entrepreneur even though it's
wildly Luke
to do what I do just on the speaking
platform I mean anybody can do the math
on 121 speeches right and the amount of
money that I get paid to show up and
deliver a one-hour talk and realize
there's a lot of money here's the
problem it's a terrible business because
you can't scale it other than raising
your price or raising the number of the
times you do it and guess what else you
have to show up and I can't sell it so I
found myself in a situation where I had
built a multi-million dollar business
highly profitable and it was depleting
the hell out of me and I can't really
scale it and I can't sell it terrible
position to be in in an entrepreneur so
I made a decision that I you know what
was it beau that actually energizes me
about my business and I answered it with
the first question it's hearing from
people I would rather answer comments on
Instagram all day long than stand in a
stadium with 5,000 people in it I get
more from the one-to-one connection
that's what fuels me and so I had this
lightbulb moment paying attention being
clear that wait a minute I don't want to
build the biggest speaking platform and
I don't want to build a coaching
business I want to build a content
company I want to go back to my roots
and build a media company and so with
that in sight I now have to change right
because the kind of businesswoman that
runs a multi multi-million dollar
speaking business is where it's just you
and your speaking management firm and
your traveled folks and your logistics
people and maybe your social media
manager that's who's on the team the
kind of leader that runs that kind of
team is very different than the kind of
leader that is going to grow a hundred
million dollar media company that's
going to syndicate content every single
day that is going to own what she's
doing that's gonna build Instagram and
Facebook and YouTube and LinkedIn as my
personal ABC CNBC Fox and this is what I
want you to understand about the story
and that is this in order to get to the
next level
in your business you got to decide right
now what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now because you
will not see around the corner you will
not engineer that next quantum leap
unless you personally change and so one
of the reasons why I have gone from
being the most successful female you
know book speaker on the speaking
circuit to launching the number one book
on all of the self-publishing platform
for Amazon and one of the most read
books in the world and selling like
gangbusters still is because I am
constantly innovating myself I know that
I am the single biggest problem in my
company and if I don't constantly pivot
and evolve how I lead and what I'm
focused on I'm gonna be the blockade and
so you know stop looking at what
everybody else is doing stop
micromanaging the team and ask yourself
two years from now when you think about
where you want your company to be what
habit do you have to change right now
and there were a couple key habits for
me number one I had to stop drinking
during the week because my go-to at
night Bo was okay five o'clock I've done
more in most days the most human beings
have in fact I've usually flown across
the country and given a speech and a
book signing and written a blog post and
FaceTime my kids so Jesus I want a
Manhattan for crying out loud the
problem is that having Manhattan even
though it tastes delicious it takes it
does something to me in terms of how I
fall asleep
and how I wake up the next day if I'm
serious about building a hundred million
dollar network of inspirational content
that we own that we're syndicating with
meaningful partnerships and products and
all kinds of cool brands that are
offshoots
I can't piece out with a drink during
the week it's not that I have to keep
working it's that the boundary setting
for myself in terms of being clear in
terms of taking care of myself it
requires me to instill that habit do I
do it every day
but do I do it most days absolutely the
second thing is busyness I am a person
that is addicted to busyness I think it
is because I'm a sexual abuse survivor
so you can tend to be the kind of person
that catch me if you can I'm on the move
and also I have anxieties so there's a
busyness about people with anxiety and I
use my busyness as an excuse for why I
don't have time to attack the hard stuff
and so looking in the mirror and saying
okay number one you got to get control
of the fact that you love to relax with
a drink during the week and you've got
to stop using busyness as an excuse and
you've got to take responsibility now
for the fact that you're the one that
said yes to all these speeches so you
now need to say no and get disciplined
about carving out production blocks
because we ain't going to be producing
the amount of content we need to produce
if your ass is always on a plane and
then the third one is around
micromanaging we have this this term in
our company around owning your lane that
we hire people that are self-starters
that are incredible at googling that can
figure out problems and that know how to
own their lane period I don't want to be
involved in things in my company and if
I'm too involved it's because I'm a
crappy manager and I have not empowered
the people around me to own their Lane
and the reason why they don't is because
they're afraid of disappointing me
hundred percent this is a hardest thing
for every single entrepreneur to
understand if you're disappointed by the
people that work for you it's your fault
and the reason why it's your fault is
because they either are afraid of you
afraid of disappointing you or they
resent you and that's because of how you
behave and how you treat them and when
you understand that and you realize you
got to pivot something in yourself it'll
change how your company operates
I can't believe we're not selling this
interview because it's so packed with
gold people there's so much in here but
so even there one of my most favorite
things to talk to people when I'm
helping them is everyone loves
motivation but discipline is is where
you carve and that's and you've just
said it there and
you've given examples of how to do it so
guys if you are listening to this yes
the point is your word that word scares
me I literally it does cuz I am I'm not
I think about pushing myself all day
because I discipline in some regard it
just feels to me and I love that you
love that word but for all the freaks
that are out there watching this let me
tell you something you can have a TV you
can have anxiety
you can feel overwhelmed and you can
still push yourself forward all the time
bow calls that discipline I call that
manipulation you can learn how to
manipulate yourself through your own and
I've never Bo become the kind of person
and maybe this is my appeal that I I
will never be the kind of person that
likes to exercise but I still do it I
will never be the kind of person that
doesn't like the drink but there are
nights that I'll make a mocktail and be
pissed about it and I'll still do it so
I feel like what I've developed which
has worked for me it may work for many
people that feel like it's a discipline
and it certainly works for Bo because
you're very successful is I have a
capacity to see my own bolt and to know
that it's coming and then to push
through and so I don't make the BS wrong
I recognize that it's part of being
human I see it and I push through and so
it's more like kind of standing in a
notion and letting the waves come you
know what I mean that's beautiful it's
you've owned it yourself for me
discipline is that I close my eyes and I
see on the mountaintop the Zen monk
being like and now it is tough that's it
for me
it's not the school teacher beating me
oh really oh I need the ruler trust me
but one of the last things which people
found I was interviewing you on here and
a lot of got so excited and they're all
fans of heavens and they said Evans one
of them Evans big things is his one word
and if people can embody a word
and really help them identify things in
life Evans word is believe mines
incredible because I the things I do are
incredible I want to live an incredible
life I want to meet incredible people
and everyone's just wondering is there
any is there any word that you associate
they go that's mine try that's a good
one you try because when you become the
kind of person that's willing to try
what happens is you take the pressure
off being perfect you take the pressure
off getting it done and and we you
you're the kind of person that's willing
to start and it's only when you start or
when you try new things that you'll gain
the competency the skillset the
experience and the failures that you
need in order to succeed and so for me
my word is try that's I've never heard
that and as soon as you said I was like
damn that's good that's awesome because
nobody's ever asked me that question but
I I when you ask me it the first thing I
thought was well I wonder if it's
confidence and that I thought no I need
to unpack confidence because I live with
the definition of confidence that is not
about belief that confidence is the
willingness to try because if you're
willing to try that means you're beating
fear it means you're moving despite self
doubt and so it is the essence of what
confidence is about and so my word is
try that's beautiful guys and maybe some
of you out there have that awesome word
and you and milk and take over the world
but not just for me mail from the
millions of people on this channel and
the hundreds of thousands people
watching it we just all want to say
thank you so much for coming out here
and doing this I think well thank you
for having me Bowen congratulations on
your new gig you're gonna crush it and
let me tell you something people watch
not because of who's being interviewed
they watch because of you so don't give
your power to Gary Vaynerchuk Wilson in
that is that people are tuning in for
you remember that and your interview
show will rock thank you
take that in I'm gonna let it marinate
into my heart thank you so much guys
check out kick-ass with Mel Robbins on
audible the five-second rule she's ever
if you've not heard of Mel Robbins you
probably live under a rock or you're on
Mars but Mel anything to say before we
go
well I think the fastest way to look at
kick-ass will just go to Mel Robbins
calm and yo we reach 20 million people a
month with social we put out a
newsletter every Thursday where we don't
sell we just give you the five things
I'm thinking about I'd love to have you
join that the information about kick-ass
is on Mel Robbins comm and that's it
just keep trying guys it's all I got to
say guys thank you so much for watching
a Mel thank you so much we'll see you
for another bow show soon my pleasure
have a good one hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that discussion with Mel Robbins
what an incredible human she really is
and in just that short 30 minutes the
amount of gems of wisdom that were in it
are countless and for me the two main
things that I took away from that
discussion were confidence is the
willingness to try to try new things to
try different paths because by doing
that I'm building my confidence and
therefore I might ignite something
within me that's gonna set me on a whole
new life journey and I might even find
something I love even more than I'm
doing right now it's how I got here
today by just following my heart and
trying different things and failure yeah
if it fails that's okay you just keep
trying and then that's the second thing
I took away from Mel what you said your
life's purpose is to listen to your
heart and soul and then to follow it how
many times we heard countless masters
say listen to your heart and follow it
we're here you've got practical advice
so I'd love to know what you took away
from this as an entrepreneur as an
innovator as a spiritual secret you
might have taken something different and
we'd love to hear what you took away in
the comments and what wisdom that you
think's gonna change your life so guys
this is the bow show what is the bow
show who's this bearded guy what's going
on
let's tell you guys so I'm bow Hawkins
I'm the creator Foreman masters but for
this I've collaborated with Evan to
bring you guys a new series a discussion
series where I interview the most
innovative successful and influential
people on the planet to inspire you guys
because I believe inside of all of you
guys you've got truly incredible pretend
within you and so someone that we
interview might unlock that even more
for you so it's not just gonna be about
business we're gonna interview business
people we're gonna interview people in
the field of health in the field of
wisdom in the field of Finance all the
way around the world we're gonna find
the best of the best and give them to
you guys because you deserve it that's
why you're here and something that
someone says might match up with
something someone else says and that
could be the key to unlock the true you
and you can go out and become the best
version of yourself in the world so guys
please if you want to talk to me write
in the comments I'd love to hear from
you what you took away from this if
there's someone you want on this series
please suggestions I'm open to it but we
will be going forward we've got some
amazing people lined up that I can
guarantee you're gonna take something
from so guys if you want to get in touch
with me I'm both Hawkins all over
Facebook both um Hawkins I can't wait to
meet you in person and online so we'll
see you for another bow show soon if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it don't you believe it
you act like it I am Tulsa what a wail
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty-four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 2:54 confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access